making his 15th start of the season his
numbers across the board are very
impressive remember he didn't make his
first start in the majors until may 27th
against the yankees he actually made
three starts in the minor leagues
and harrison second pitch of the game
lines it into left center field for a
base hit so josh harrison doing a nice
job out of that lead off spot and that's
how the ball game starts so that'll
bring up starling marte
marte lines on the left and that's a
base hit so the pitch was up marta took
advantage
and the a's have two on nobody out here
in the first matt olson the first
baseman there's a swing at a high fly
ball out to left field guriel drifting
back to his left underneath it to make a
play he's there runners block the tag
one out so two singles of fly ball to
left and a walk and chapman's coming up
with he is a shot to break through in
the top of the first and here's the o2
pitch swung on and drilled to left
center field guri all back at the track
in he's gonna play it off the wall one
run is in here's marte around third and
he comes to the plate on a double by
chapman lowry goes to third in the
athletic seven early 2 nothing lead in a
huge hit for chapman right off the top
tonight the blue jays say manoa the a's
say mania and shawn minaya right now
kaite making his 123rd start of his
career and that right there that's the
most by an ace pitcher over the last 18
years george springer leads off for the
blue jays 3-2 pitch is swung on and
missed on a fast ball up springer case
and marcus coming up
good fastball 96 miles an hour mania
with back-to-back strikeouts to open up
his start tonight and now with two down
and the base is empty here's vladimir
guerrero jr there's a swing and a line
drive base it right up the middle
that'll extend that hit straight to
11 straight games 15 for 41 now during
that hit streak here's bo buchet and he
rips a base hit into left field heading
towards the corner long run by kemp to
cut it off he slides to a stop in the
corner
guerrero goes to third and bow's got
another two bagger blue jays threatening
with two out in the 01 pitch by sean and
that's swung on that's it to right
center hit well but marty has a play and
he makes the catch and the inning is
over guerrero line to base it into
center with two outs back in the first
and another base hit for guerrero this
one into right field runner back in
first tesco hernandez comes up to oscar
with a fly ball to set her hit it well
yeah and this is a team he hasn't had
much success against
this might help though deep to left
field and there it goes
and boy is that a good sign for a guy
who has been due as tay oscar hernandez
ties the game before he sat back and
waited on that breaking ball to break
and connected for his 23rd home run of
the season so there's manoa doing his
duty starting pitcher says hey keep it
up man uriel a fly ball to ride his
first time up
at the knees strike three called home
run for t oscar hernandez a two run shot
we're headed to the fifth 12 out of the
last 13 pushed aside by manoa top of the
order and it's josh harrison
oh and that one came way inside and it
hit him harrison flips the bat way up
he's not happy takes a glance at manoa
so they're glancing at each other a
little bit so here's marte
and that hit marte in the head harrison
is not happy kemp's not happy none of
the a's are happy and you can't blame
them and marty is down keep your fingers
crossed and nick paparez is out there
the a's head athletic trainer and starly
marty is still down in the a's all the
a's are out on the warning track in
front of their dugout up the first base
side it's three straight pitches in a
very uncomfortable area and whether or
not i mean you're not thinking it's
intentional by manoa but the a's aren't
happy about it right you don't want to
see you don't like to see that it looks
like marte's gonna stay in the game
thank goodness so marty at first
harrison his second a 2-2 tie one out
top of the fifth and here's matt olson
and he lines one fair ball
into the right field corner harrison
will score marte's digging around third
they're gonna wave him home here comes
the throw to the plate and it is late
martay scores and the a's lead 4-2
olson comes through he got a another
fastball
and he took advantage of it you gotta
love every minute of that if you're the
oakland a's and matt olson and company
tell me they're not pumped up here sky
bolt is coming the game in center field
so
unfortunately starling marte has come
out of the game kevin smith ninth place
sitters the one-two pitch is swung on
and missed so canada
ball was in the dirt it could be some
dirt flew up in the eye which you see it
does happen at home plates it happens to
catch her sometimes when they have to
block a ball yeah they have something
and jeff is applying something to his
eye
back in there
kemp hits one high in the air toward
right field that's hernandez near the
wall and that baby is gone six to two
the a's lead kemp homers for the sixth
time this year he's become a great story
on this ball club just got it just
barely over the wall and right at the
rogers center and that's going to be it
for young alec manoa trevor richards
into the game 2-1 that's in the air
towards the gap in left-center field off
the bat of andrews on the run grichik
reaches out and he reels it in oh my
goodness full extension staying upright
then taking his last two steps bracing
for impact here's vlad junior guerrero
bechet and hernandez
change up and a good one and he gets
guerrero swinging eight strikeouts for
sean manaya here's bo buschetta's
doubled and struck out
and a fastball and buchet chased it way
out of the strike zone back-to-back
strikeouts here in the sixth give him
nine now well he is back after an
injury-plagued season that has seen him
make only one appearance in the major
leagues nate pearson is now back as a
reliever at least for the remainder of
this season second and third nobody out
the infielders creep in here's matt
chapman
that ball's hit up the middle base hit
center field
olson will score lowry will go to third
stop there matt chapman with his second
run scoring hit he's got three rbis and
it's now seven to two the a's lead and
here comes tony kemp
kemp grounds it into right field and
that's the base sit lowry will score
chapman to second
and another big hit for the athletics
this one belongs to tony kim he has a
three rbi game and now it's eight to two
sean manaya back out there for the
bottom of the seven two outs best ball
skied behind second base josh harrison
waiting for it to come down j hey wait
makes the catch one two three
and it only took six pitches for mania a
much needed
great start for mania sure was moon
trevino comes in from the bullpen for
the a's to pick up from anaya we go to
the bottom of the eighth valera takes
second base now a two down for vladi
and he's got another base hit
valera around third
and he will come in to score rbi single
for vladi and it's eight to three three
hit night for vladimir guerrero jr bases
are loaded bottom of the eighth it's
eight to three samara petite is gonna
come in alejandro kirk up with the bases
loaded and two down three two again
all four to force in a run and it's
eight to four this oakland athletics
bullpen is doing it to bob melvin again
and the battery is lourdes guriel jr
representing the tying run
and he drives into left field
and he has tied it
[Applause]
[Music]
from out of nowhere the blue jays scores
six runs here in the bottom of the
eighth to tie the game
guerrielle hits his third grand slam of
the season and it's back to square one
421
feet and the ants have a start with a go
ahead run it first two away and here's
walked and scored in the sixth
and that one is lined down the left
field line and
that baby is gone canada with a two run
shot into the left field corner and the
a's lead
he was able to get the head out on one
of those high octane fastballs and mark
canna maybe the biggest hit of the year
it's all up to you sergio baseball gods
have had other plans this evening so
that brings up the tying run and a guy
with a lot of power of course in george
springer one for four on the night with
a double
hooks it to left field and that ball is
gonna get down
valera's going to be held at third it's
another double for springer the tying
runs are in scoring position winning run
at the plate with nobody out marcus
simeon tying runs aboard here in the
bottom of the ninth and everybody's
standing here at rogers center
fastball hit high and deep to left field
and the blue jays win it
his heart had to be pounding as he was
rounding the bases he just needed to
know did i keep it fair
you betcha and what a gut punch to his
old team one of the most dramatic
comebacks we have ever seen here at
rogers center and marcus
with a three-run home run beats his
former team
with a career-high 34th home run
what a ball game
[Applause]
you